he served more than a year over 25-year
prison sentence after a random Court
convicted him on terrorism charges now
Paul recesser beginner is a free man two
years ago he refused to participate in
court proceedings write scripts and
observers said the trial was a sham the
kiss of Medina have showed to the old
how the the nature of the Rwandan
government because it does not it does
not tolerate criticism and so it it is
shared the right to the to the system of
Rwanda of the the dictatorship that's
why the the social media have been
fighting for for human rights in one of
the Democracy in Rwanda and he he
eventually become a victim it is very
exciting nearly 20 years earlier he
became famous when the Hollywood film
Rwanda told his story
his creditor was saving more than 1200
lives during rwanda's 1994 genocide more
than half a million tootsies and many
Hooters were killed by a Hooter militia
during a civil war
the Rondon patriotic front led by Paul
kagame won the war and took power kagame
later became president and recesser
beginner became his critic Ronda accused
him of supporting an armed group that
wanted to overthrow the government
we have maintained our serious concerns
about this case especially as regards
um political violence by armed groups
including those that are led by people
operating from developed countries
but uh we have uh now agreed uh on on on
fundamental uh principles and uh we're
able to to move forward with this
humanitarian release recessive beginner
has Belgian citizenship and was a
resident of the US
three years ago he was deceived into
boarding a plane in Dubai and later
appeared in rwanda's capital Kigali in
handcuffs
rights groups say he was kidnapped
rwanda's government says his sentence
has been commuted after a presidential
order
Barbara angopa Al Jazeera